chaque année au mois de juin le réseau
entreprendre en yvelines fait ces
lauréats à versailles en 2015 ils sont
treize à être soutenu et financé par
l'association
parmi eux l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement basée à trappes
grâce au réseau entreprendre on
bénéficie d'un accompagnement
personnalisé
on bénéficie d'un soutien financier puis
parallèlement ça nous permet pour nous
de d'encre et plus fortement l'école
dans son réseau local des entreprises
des yvelines
ce qui est très important pour garantir
une bonne insertion professionnelle de
nos jeunes tous les lauréats yvelinois
reçoivent un prêt d'honneur pour cette
école le montant s'élève à 40 mille
euros de quoi se développer et surtout
créer de l'emploi
objectif premier c'est d'accompagner la
création d'emplois et donc nous
accompagnons des entreprises ils
s'engagent à créer 5 à 10 emplois au
minimum dans les deux à trois ans
donc là la fête de lauréats des chaque
année une grande opportunité de mettre à
l'honneur ces gens qui ont été méritants
et qui ont mérité d'être labellisé par
des 30 recoins c'est nicolas beytout le
parrain de la promotion 2015 créateur du
journal l'opinion
il est venu rencontrer chaque lauréat
c'est quelqu'un qui effectivement a créé
son entreprise donc c'est à la fois
effectivement un journaliste économique
et en même temps l'entrepreneur il
connaît le monde de l'entreprise et
surtout en 2016 quoi on connaît les
difficultés depuis la création de réseau
entreprendre en yvelines en 2009
l'association a accompagné une centaine
d'entreprises et les résultats sont
concluants
trois ans après 91 % de ces entreprises
sont pérennes